the president said that he in fact
believes the me - times up movement
might be going too far
that in fact it is dangerous how did you
get home I don't remember how'd you get
there don't remember where is the place
I don't remember how many years ago was
it I don't know I can't change what the
president has said but I can at least
put my body in the way and say listen
don't listen to that this is the real
narrative we have to stick together I
started the me2 movement in 2006 because
I was working with black girls in Selma
Alabama I was constantly confronted with
their stories of sexual violence
breaking news just moments ago Harvey
Weinstein surrendered to police here in
New York City than 2017 over ten years
after the me2 movement was founded
Harvey Weinstein was exposed as a sexual
predator and a tweet from a Hollywood
celebrity sparked a viral moment it kind
of lit a fire across this country
millions across the world said me too
when the hashtag first started trending
my first reaction was definitely panic I
was afraid that it was going to be not
understood for what it had actually
started as
me too is a movement ultimately to end
sexual violence while our issue is
definitely married to other issues like
pay equity and gender equity and this is
specifically a movement about the
spectrum of sexual violence from sexual
harassment all the way to murder when
people tried to make me to an umbrella
that covers everything that has to do
with women in particular it definitely
makes it harder
the meter movement is not about naming
and shaming in the last year we've seen
huge focus on individual bad actors it's
not a movement to just deal with
individual people if you're not gonna
uproot and the reasons why those people
were allowed to behave in a way they
behave our goal is to shift the
narrative so that we our focus is on the
millions and millions of people who
actually said meet you
those people bravely came forward and
told their stories by and large what
we're dealing with are people who have
been so shamed into silence but they've
been holding on to deep traumas for
decades sexual violence doesn't
discriminate in the last year people
from the most marginalized groups
particularly black and brown people
disabled people queer people trans
people they have been erased from the
popular narrative when you only see
famous white rich women in the media it
does not feel like there's space for you
the meatsuit movement is not a movement
just for women this all the space in the
world in this movement for men this is a
movement for all of us so we can live in
a world together it looks different me
too is not online activism in order for
the me to movement to survive and for us
to end sexual violence society would
have to form a new shared idea about how
we behave we have to collectively
understand what accountability looks
like we have to collectively agree on
what it means to respect somebody's
humanity everybody has a role to play in
ending sexual violence I know what
happens when we stand up together we've
seen it now and so I'm ready to see it
more
[Music]